nearly 15 million people in parts of
Texas and the South East face a new
threat today of severe weather tornadoes
ripped across parts of western Texas
yesterday at least 14 were reported the
violent system also brought damaging
hail some almost as big as tennis balls
as the storm moves East states from the
plains to the Gulf Coast are at risk
they could face dangerous conditions
today including possible tornado Omar
Villafranca is in Arlington Texas where
the storm caused new damage overnight
Omar good morning good morning this is
the second round of severe weather to
blow through North Texas just this week
last night's storm that came through dfw
had straight-line winds we're talking
gusts of more than 70 miles per hour and
now people are waking up to this pieces
of their roofs lying in the street
fences blown over and trees split in
half overnight severe storms swept
across Texas and Oklahoma with damaging
winds heavy rain and Counting hail on
Tuesday tornadoes tore through the
western part of the state tornado on the
ground from a no on the ground more than
a dozen twisters were reported including
this one near Stanford oh my god the
triggered warning sirens why don't you
get over here and let's go inside
further south in the Abilene area we've
got her lowering right here a funnel
cloud dark into the sky 100 miles north
co 3 storm chasers died when their cars
collided after one ran a stop sign a
tornado watch was in effect at the time
a blinding combination of rain and hail
created brutal conditions on the roads
some hail stones were large enough to
smash through car windows my back we
sure will bust it out
and it hit my daughter in the back of
the head outside of lubbock hail pellets
blanketed the ground in Oklahoma the
powerful storm blew over semi trucks on
the highway the worst of the storm will
blow through Arkansas and Louisiana
today as four people here in North Texas
they're waking up in the dark more than
150,000 people still do not have power
and there are more storms in the
forecast for this weekend Nora all right
Omar thank you so much